Air pollution, energy insecurity, and global
warming - fixing these huge problems may seem
impossible. But we don't need a miracle. We
can save our Earth and clean our air and we can
start right now using the technology we already
have. I'm Mark Jacobson, a Professor of civil and
environmental engineering at Stanford University.
In this course I'll take you inside my classroom
and share the science and strategies for building
clean renewable energy and storage for everything.
From our transportation system and electricity
infrastructure, to our industries and businesses
you will learn about the key technologies for
harnessing the power of the wind, the water,
and the sun with storage to meet all our energy
needs. You will also learn how to make power grids
efficient, resilient, and dependable anywhere in
the world, and how to develop and Implement a road
map to transition your country, state, community,
or business to 100 clean renewable energy.
You don't have to be a scientist or an engineer.
These lessons are for anyone who wants to
understand the latest research about what works
what doesn't and why. We'll explain everything
from photovoltaics, to hydroelectricity, to wind
turbines, to batteries, to electrolyzers, to heat
pumps, and show you why renewable electricity
generation and storage won't just save our planet
it'll also create new job opportunities from
energy to manufacturing. Whether you work in
business, government, education, or the nonprofit
sector this foundational course will give you the
practical knowledge you need to communicate
about those important issues with confidence,
transform your organization, and
contribute to a healthier planet.